[Musique]
thierry renard bonjour bonjour monsieur
vous hri bonjour à toute la martinique
vous êtes le porte parole de la france
insoumise et l'un des porte parole de
l'avenir en commun de jean luc mélenchon
alors que pensez-vous du gouvernement
macron eu un gouvernement marche main le
gouvernement manque ont ainsi un
gouvernement de la finance
c'est un gouvernement extrêmement
cohérent sur ce principe donc et c'est
un gouvernement qui est là pour détruire
le code du travail
d'ailleurs muriel pénicaud qui a été
qu'est la ministre du travail
elle a été nommée pour cela donc
aujourd'hui nous savons que ce
gouvernement va s'attaquer directement
aux travailleurs directement à toutes
les valeurs sociales qui ont été mises
en place depuis des décennies pour aider
le monde de la finance pour aider non
pas les entrepreneurs mais les grosses
entreprises
jean luc mélenchon dit que si un
gouvernement de droite et horta g7 cette
analyse oui parce que en
on a l'habitude de classifier la finance
avec la droite et mais c'est un
gouvernement de droite et de la finance
d'accord mais il ya quand même quelque
chose de quelques trucs positifs quand
même quelque chose de positif dans ce
gouvernement
par exemple le nicolas hulot ministère
de la transition écologique n'est pas
positif oui c'est extrêmement positif
nicolas hulot nicolas hulot
malheureusement doit servir de caution
parce que l'écologie et la finance ne
font pas bon ménage l'écologie fait bon
ménage avec l'humanisme au la finance
c'est d'abord l'argent donc pour faire
de l'argent ont détruit souvent la terre
ont détruit les richesses de la terre
pour faire des bénéfices donc l'écologie
c'est simplement la caution et ceux ci
sont dommage que ce soit nicolas hulot
qui se soit porté caution pour ce
gouvernement de la finance
un ex girardin ministre de d outre mer
oui je ne rêvais pas je ne la connais
pas personnellement j'ai pas vraiment
réfléchi à la chose comme le disait jean
notre parti dans son édito en échappée
au mystère du zouk parce qu on contourne
toujours les antilles soit alors au
ministère d outre-mer ou bien là par
exemple leur à flesselles aux sports
alors jeune je ne vais pas voir ça comme
ça je pense que c'est une grande
sportive qui a déjà une mission c'est
pareil 2024 donc il fallait quelqu'un
qui représente la france qui représente
le sport
donc c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
beaucoup
malheureusement se retrouve dans ce
gouvernement
c'est mon point de vue mais parce que à
côté d'elle
il n'y a quasiment que des financiers et
que des gens qui sont là pour aider le
monde de la finance en fait le troisième
voire même le 4e tour le troisième tour
sont les législatives le quatrième tour
pour vous c'est le tour de la rue
c'est le pouvoir qui va pouvoir s'il va
pouvoir de la rue qui va pouvoir faire
infléchir les législatives sont le
troisième et le quatrième tour la rue
c'est ce sont les gens qui pour la
plupart ne se sont pas exprimés lors des
élections qui ne sont pas content de ce
qui se passe c'est pour ça que nous
disons aux gens il faut voter le 10 et
le 17 juin
il faut aller voter allez voter pour des
candidats qui vont défendre vos justes
aspirations n'allait pas ne restez pas
chez vous en vous disant c'est blanc
bonnet et bonnet blanc
non il y à des candidats nous la france
est soumise
nous avons des candidats qui nous avons
un seul candidat
faut dire la vérité c'est notre
programme qui l'avenir en commun et nous
tous nous sommes des porte parole de
ceux de ce programme
donc si vous voulez que le programme la
venue en commun soit mise en place
il faut voter pour les candidats de la
france un smic vous avez justement
présentez-vous candidats aux
législatives pour la matinée que qu'est
ce qui a motivé cette envie de passer du
soutien à jean-luc mélenchon pour la
présidentielle à l'implication plus
personnel dans les législatives alors à
faire une petite actifs ication nous ne
soutenons pas jean-luc mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon était le porte parole du
programme l'avenir en commun donc nous
soutenons tous sa venue en commun est la
figure de proue c'était jean luc
mélenchon d'accord donc nous avons pas
changer de candidat entre ces deux
élections
donc oui mais comment on passe de jolis
prince haiti facile pour moi c était
facile étant le porte parole de la
france est soumise pendant la campagne
présidentielle
c était naturel qu'on m'ait demandé de
me présenter en tant que porte parole
dans notre programme la venue en commun
alors viens vous êtes à fond de france
viager a dit géraldine de toreo centre
karine varas au nord et à l'est kg c'est
ça dans le sud eux c'est ça et ça ne
vous a pas échappé que
à parité chez nous c'est une réalité
c'est à dire que ce sont toujours des
hommes et une femme et ce ne sont pas
quatre hommes qui sont en première
position suivie de quatre femmes mais
bien deux femmes dans les deux première
circonscription
peut-être qu'ils sont titulaires et deux
hommes dans les deux autres
circonscriptions qui sont titulaires à
lancer une édition particulière il ya
beaucoup de candidats dans chaque
circonscription parfois 10 12 13 15
voilà la démocratie monsieur il faut
bien sûr que moi comment vous allez
faire pour vous faire entendre
et comment vous allez faire pour vous
c'est vous vous démarquez mais on va
faire comme on a l'habitude de faire et
à dire mais et c'est à dire qu'on va
mener la même campagne que nous avions
menée lors des élections présidentielles
je vous signale que nous avons toujours
le même candidat est notre candidat
c'est notre programme je ne pense pas
que les autres ont ce genre de candidat
il se présente de façon intuitive
personae voilà c'est eux nous c'est
notre programme oui mais il ya quand
même le difficile d'image mais l'image
effet sophie reconnaître quand même
d'accord le programme mais il faut se
faire connaître il faut aller au devant
des gens comment vous comptez faire ça
mais chaque candidat ira au devant de la
population de sa circonscription
chaque candidat se passe comme en porte
à porte
meeting grand meeting comment ça va se
passer concrètes alors nous ne ferons
pas de grand meeting
nous ferons des prises de parole parce
que vous savez ici en martinique les
gens n'aiment pas trop ça
ils ont les gens vous disent toujours ça
ça leur casse les oreilles
donc quand vous faites une prise de
parole qui est trop long vous embêter
100 personnes et vous en fédérer 3 donc
nous préférons faire de petites
rencontres chez l'habitant on appelle ce
entre guillemets des réunions tupperware
ou chaque fois on va voir dix personnes
15 personnes on en fait 4-5 dans une
journée
ce qui nous permet et ben de fédérer
plus de gens de parler
nous avons toujours la même méthode
on doit convaincre une personne à la
fois et une personnes convaincues va en
convaincre une note
et ça fait boule de neige d'accord alors
sur les thèmes que vous allez développer
donc trois grands chapitres c'est ça
l'urgence écologique urgences sociales
et urgence démocratique
oui tout à fait c'est c'est notre
programme est voué aux gens ce chaque
fois mais bien parce qu'il ya urgence 1
alors la démocratie vous avez bien vu
que les gens veulent que ça change
bon d'impôts que ça change il faut déjà
changé les élus donc on met des nouveaux
des neuf
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas choisi jean
le choix pour les législatives n'ont pas
encore pour les présidentielles ils ont
pris un candidat par défaut ce qui nous
désole mais que voulez vous mais pour
les législatives n'ont pas encore choisi
regardez dans la circonscription de fort
de france il y en a quatorze ya choix
d'accord en ce moment vous êtes aussi un
peu divisé pense que l' aventure
mélenchon il ya là dedans qui a la
france est soumise
et puis on sûr vous retrouvez avec les
insoumis de martinique un mouvement
jeune ça fait déjà
voilà ça fait voilà il ya un peu déjà de
l'eau dans le gaz dans les insomnies il
n'ya pas d'autre dans gaza dans les
insoumis je crois que le candidat dont
vous parlez c'est très clairement
expliqué il ne se reconnaissait pas dans
notre programme la venue en commun donc
il a crié son propre au mouvement
nous sommes très contents de voir que la
nous avons pu aider de manière indirecte
candidats en manque d'inspiration
puisque il cherche un nom et on a aidé
n'y avait pas moyen de vous entendre
vous savez ce que vous reprochez vous
reproduisez quand même les mêmes schémas
que les anciens pas non non nous ne
reproduisons pas nous ne reproduisons
pas les mêmes schémas pour la simple et
bonne raison que nous avons nous un
candidat
ce candidat c'est l'avenir en commun et
nous sommes là pour porter la vanille en
commun toute personne qui ait la peau
porter ses propres idées ne peut pas
représenter l'avenir en commun donc ils
ne représentaient pas la venue en commun
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il ya eu les
investitures
il ne s'est même pas présenté et dont
peu nous n'avons rien à voir avec ce
jeune homme qui très ambitieux au
demeurant et qui n'est pas à sa première
élection et nous n'utilisons et ben nous
lui souhaitons quand même bonne chance
parce que bah faut bien que les gens
aillent se présenter aux élections est
passée la démocratie focaux la
démocratie vive et c'est ça au second
tour vous allez appeler vous à voter
pour qui au second tour nous allons
appeler à voter pour la france est
soumise pour nous parce que nous serons
au second tour
enfin deux voies je ne vois pas du tout
où vous voyez comment
comment pouvez vous penser que un groupe
qui sortit dans toutes les
circonscriptions premiers se retrouvent
ne se retrouvent pas au second tour
soyons sérieux thierry renard je vous
remercie merci d'avoir été notre invité
est bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes
merci roi
[Musique]